وهكذا ما
قاله الرئيس الحادي عشر بالأمس كنا
نتحدث في الغالب عن
أه الفيروس وأعتقد أنه سيكون
في حالة جيدة ولكنك تعلم أنه موقف
صعب للغاية
إنه أه يمر عبر الهواء
وهو دائمًا أصعب من  اللمسة التي
تعرفها هي اللمسة التي لا يجب عليك لمس
الأشياء بشكل صحيح ولكن الهواء
الذي تتنفسه للهواء فقط وهذه هي الطريقة
التي يتم تمريرها
، وبالتالي فهذه لمسة صعبة
للغاية وهي حساسة للغاية ،
إنها أيضًا أكثر فتكًا مما
تعرفه  حتى إنفجارك الشاق ، كما تعلم ،
لا يدرك الناس أننا نفقد خمسة وعشرين
ألفًا وثلاثين ألف شخص سنويًا
هنا ،
والذين قد يظن أن هذا صحيح ، وأنا أعلم
أن هذا مذهل
جدًا ، ثم أقول جيدًا أن نفس
الشيء
لهذا الأمر أكثر فتكًا ، هذا هو  خمسة لكل
أنت تعلم أن هذا هو خمسة في المائة مقابل واحد في
المائة وأقل من واحد في المائة
كما تعلم ، لذا فهذه أشياء مميتة الآن
اتضح أنه ليس فقط كبار
السن بوب الذي ظهر اليوم وأمس
بعض الحقائق المذهلة  إنها ليست
مجرد عجوز ،
نعم بالضبط أشخاص كثيرون من الشباب ،
لذا
ما هي
لحظة التحدث إلى شخص ما يمر
بهذا الأمر مع
الفاوشي أو شخص
ما تسبب نوعًا ما في حدوث تحول في ذهنك
لأنه واضح
فقط مما هو موجود في الجمهور  سجل
أنك
مررت بمحاور حول هذا يا إلهي ، الجاذبية
لا يمكن تفسيرها تقريبًا ولا يمكن
تفسيرها جيدًا ، أعتقد أن بوب
حقًا سيكون صادقًا معك بالتأكيد أريدك
أن أرغب في ذلك ،
كنت أرغب دائمًا في اللعب بها باستمرار ،
ما زلت أحب  قللها
نعم لأنني لا أريد أن أخلق
حالة من الذعر ،
لذا فهمت الآن أن
مستشار الأمن القومي الجديد الخاص بك
أوبراين
قال لك في 28 يناير
السيد الرئيس أن هذا الفيروس سيكون
أكبر
تهديد للأمن القومي  رئاستك
هل تتذكر لا لا لا لا لا لا
اعرف انا لست متأكدا اذا قلت ذلك انت
تعلم انا متأكد انه قالها يا رجل لطيف